he's the wisecracking television host
who has challenged the way we get news
our show obviously is at a disadvantage
compared to the many other news sources
that we are competing with for one thing
we are fake comedian Jon Stewart has
altered the media landscape assuring and
biting political satire that crosses
generations the media has been here
doing a superb job giving the convention
a perfunctory superficial backwards
analysis it deserves she's hysterical e
funny just off-the-cuff funny he's
smaller than the world leaders and
politicians in abuse he seized a central
role in American culture by attacking
the cherished conventions of journalism
somehow John is broken through by
turning the media culture on its head I
would think that goes without saying
I consider him a branch of government he
has become one of the backstops he's
become one of the people who keep you
honest his razor-sharp takedowns and
parodies have also made him into one of
the most credible voices in America with
one of the most desirable television
audiences the last person that we had in
America that people trusted was Walter
Cronkite now it's John Stewart
in just these past few weeks I have
disemboweled I have mauled
I have hammered I have destroyed for 11
years from behind his fake news desk at
the Daily Show Jon Stewart has conducted
a nightly send up of the news and news
makers that dominate our airwaves his
tongue-in-cheek commentary on the issues
of the day has made him the Mark Twain
of the digital age you guys watch our
show I call him the ultimately
unknowable Jon Stewart in many ways
Jon's an anachronism in a stay out late
party it up industry he's a go home
after work guy he cares deeply about his
city on about his country and about his
family he's a very driven guy he's a
very driven guy he is principled he's
like a mensch you know he's also a
handsome man which he hates me saying to
him if you want to shut Jon up if you're
a politician and he's given you just
just say you're a you're a handsome man
he hates it bad wine Jon Stewart was
born in New York City in 1962 but he's
really a Jersey guy through and through
there's the New Jersey skyline
[Music]
he attended Lawrence High School a few
blocks from his childhood home in
Lawrenceville New Jersey where he lived
with his mother and brother after his
parents divorced his American literature
instructor Larry Nichol was an early
influence he was called Jonathan
Jonathan Leibovitz John was a very
obviously a very bright guy
John's proud of his Jewish roots his mom
is a nationally recognized educational
consultant
Stewart's father was also an educator
teaching physics at the College of New
Jersey and his brother Larry Leibovitz
became a high-ranking executive at the
New York Stock Exchange
Stewart declined to participate in this
program but did revisit his old high
school with the news crew in 1999 it's
nice to know that high school kids are
still much taller than I am
even in high school his old literature
instructor noticed his wit and keen
interest in politics says I was one of
the coolest teachers that taught
politically incorrect books condemning
you know some of the hypocrisy in our
society and I think John just jumped on
admin at the end of the 70s the country
was on the edge of political change
Ronald Reagan was who was elected and we
had a conservative movement in the
country John was at the brink of a
cultural shift after graduating in 1980
Leibowitz enrolled in the College of
William and Mary studying psychology and
playing soccer at a 2004 commencement
address that his alma mater Stewart
talked about his time there
I came to William & Mary because as a
Jewish person I wanted to explore the
rich tapestry of Judaica that is
southern Virginia after college he
changed his name from Jon Leibowitz to
Jon Stewart and began his journey to
break into comedy but it wasn't easy
Stewart worked a string of odd jobs
busboy health department and the
requisite New York bartender three years
after he graduated from college Stewart
got a break at an underground Comedy
Club in New York City called the Comedy
Cellar there he met club owner Bill
grunt fest I had given Tuesdays at 11:00
over to open mic nights which are viewed
by most people as what they are which is
a punishment from God and up comes this
guy I would say stiff but stiff ish I
won't say meek like Woody Allen kind of
meek but meek like and he was getting
he was bombing he was dying a horrible
horrible death which I found endlessly
amusing still grunt fest saw something
that caught his attention in the young
comic I was going wait a second there's
an actual point of view at work here and
that's something that you don't see
every day he's not afraid he's not
self-conscious and he does not have
contempt for the audience grunt fist
asks Stewart to come back and eventually
made him late night club MC it would
become Stewart's first regular job in
stand-up comedy the Comedy Cellar was
basic training for up and comers and
Stewart was in very good company
comedian Colin Quinton was a regular
when I've never seen him down here on
stage one night oh he's funny you know
which is not easy for comedians to say
if somebody's funny when John became a
regular I'm sure it was a big deal to
him this was the place you had to be
good to work you have to connect cuz
it's just too many people walking
through this towards going on he can't
just go up here and ever phone it and
the crowd just turns on you John as a
big star even before he became a big
star had an unerring instinct about what
he could make work and very quickly he
started to play to that strength
[Music]
after a brief stint as a comedy writer
for a cable network show called
Caroline's comedy our Jon Stewart landed
in front of the camera today is national
talk show host day it was 1991 and two
fledgling cable comedy rivals comedy
channel and ha merged to form Comedy
Central they immediately launched new
programming including the show called
short attention span theater with Jon
Stewart and Patty Ross Perot as hosts we
both were auditioning for short
attention span theater evidently we have
chemistry that's what they said that's
when they hired us ever the comedic
improviser Stuart soon carved out a
place for himself
often to the dismay of the show's
writers what did you get we would have
this copy that the writers would write
for us and was supposed to be funny but
it wasn't really funny and John was like
I'm not reading this I'm like really
what are we gonna do and he take it he's
just throw in the garbage because okay
let's just talk about something happened
today I think we're trying to elevate
ourselves exactly and we are first up by
wearing high heels it was political at
all it was the antithesis of politically
time for the cavity update ding ding
Stewart left short attention span
theater in less than a year but had
caught the television bug he went on to
star in a new comedy show for MTV called
you wrote it you watch it fair to say as
Stewart later acknowledged nobody
watched it it was cancelled after just
one season with short attention span
theater and another failed show under
his belt
Stewart was hardly a familiar face but
his comedic gifts were clearly visible
to television talent executives Stewart
was considered a finalist to replace the
departing Letterman at NBC eventually
losing the spot to Conan O'Brien I was
up for his job I ended up doing a
stand-up audition in Los Angeles for
Lauren Michaels and the rest of the crew
and I I don't think I got it
I haven't been notified yet but I'm
pretty sure
[Music]
the consolation prize was a show
developed for him on MTV called the Jon
Stewart Show or as I like to call it
Waterloo
what is it about you that you think will
make it work late at night my love of
language I don't know
yet again despite critical success after
10 months it too was cancelled but this
time while on the comedy circuit steward
had earned the respect of other
influential and successful comics the
final guest on the Jon Stewart Show was
David Letterman who promptly signed
Stewart to his production company
worldwide pants he landed guest
appearances on sitcoms and the highly
acclaimed Larry Sanders show and was a
stand-in for late-night talk-show host
Tom Schneider
he also starred in an HBO special he
spent eight months writing a collection
of humorous essays naked pictures of
famous people it became a New York Times
bestseller but Stewart had not found a
regular series on television acting and
that went well until people saw him in
the running to host every talk variety
show in the world and it would always
come down to it being between him and
the guy who got the job and I think that
that kind of sobering really helped him
in a great way that he is not lost
he never said things like you know what
I'm gonna take over the Tonight Show I
mean I'm sure he had those dreams what
Stewart did not know was that the
defining role of his career was finally
on the horizon the reason that I don't
think he envisioned what's happened to
him is because no one could have
envisioned
this Jon Stewart was poised to break out
for years he was the talented talk show
host who was almost the next big thing
in 1996 Comedy Central created yet
another new late-night talk show it was
called The Daily Show and featured
original host Craig Kilborn three years
later Kilbourne left The Daily Show Jon
Stewart got his break welcome welcome to
The Daily Show Craig Kilborn is on
assignment in Kuala Lumpur I'm Jon
Stewart Washington bureau chief for The
Daily Beast Howard Kurtz what separated
Jon Stewart is this voracious appetite
that he has for politics and media and
this is a guy who really gets ticked off
about things he doesn't like in terms of
political hypocrisy or media
superficiality and that increasingly
came across on his Daily Show as he
found his voice and the fake
correspondents and all of that in a way
that kind of put the media to shame do
not listen to this guy or this guy
Stewart signed a four-year deal with
Comedy Central reportedly worth six
million dollars he had just two months
to prepare for his first show which
featured guest Michael J Fox almost
immediately
Stewart style began to take hold he
combines a comedians flair with the
satirist sharp-edged in a way that
appeals to both you know 19 year-old
kids in a dormitory who are having a
little bit too much wine and you know
middle-aged journalists even though
they're often the ones being mocked what
do you see that we journalists don't see
I can't tell you how many times we'll
run into a journalist and go boy that's
I wish we could we I wish we could be
saying that that's exactly the way we
see and that's exactly the way we'd like
to be saying that
I always think well why don't you I'm a
tiny neurotic man standing in the back
of the room throwing tomatoes at the
chalkboard and that's really it well not
all of it his personal life was taking
off too he announced his engagement to
Tracey McShane and the couple married in
2000 the year also delivered a comedians
gift the 2000 election or as The Daily
Show called it choose or lose I think
that the spirit of 2000 election put Jon
Stewart and The Daily Show on the map
right now now now now wait a minute the
2000 election was such perfect John
Stuart material the whole thing was so
absurd because this was really happening
it's actually a tie I was not elected to
serve one party you were not elected
it's perfect when you have a foil you
know every great movie they're they're
the heroes fighting against you know
Darth Vader and whatever so he had Bush
I mean you couldn't ask for anything
better for him it was clear Comedy
Central's six million dollar investment
and Stewart paid off viewership for The
Daily Show had soared 27 percent in just
over a year Michael Wolfe was president
and CEO of MTV Networks we were very
excited that The Daily Show really
struck a chord with so much of the
audience and it became the linchpin of
Comedy Central and so critical to
Viacom's growth Viacom the parent
company of Comedy Central CBS and MTV
had a new hit franchise on their hands
this is the end of my career now what
comedian and actor Ricky Gervais The
Daily Show is quite simply the cleverest
comedy show on television wickedly
satirical and it's charming as well it's
not intimidating it's not sneering it's
not biased and it's brave and it's and
it's
that honesty was on display the week
after 9/11 how comics deal with whether
it's Kennedy assassination or RFK
assassination or Martin Luther King or
9/11 it's one of the trickier things for
a comedian to deal with the guys like
Carson and guys like Jon Stewart do it
with great elegance a lot of folks have
asked me what are you gonna do when you
get back what are you gonna say I mean
not geez what a terrible thing to have
to do and and I don't see it as a burden
at all I I see it as a privilege and I
just I see it as a privilege and
everyone here does see it that way in
that moment he seemed to speak for a
much larger audience
the funny man was about to tackle some
serious issues in October of 2004
Stuart's comedy took a significant and
quite serious turn when he mounted an
attack on the partisan shouting matches
that cable networks offered as standard
fare John Stewart goes on crossfire and
he decides not to play a polite guest I
made a special effort to come on the
show today because I have privately
amongst my friends and also in
occasional newspapers and television
children mentioned this show as being
bad he was sort of like being these
so-called political analysts and
journalists at their own game
he was sort destroying them NBC News
anchor Brian Williams crossfire opened
the curtain on an era of partisan
arguing as television programming it was
news as sporting event the thing that I
want to say is when you have people on
for just a knee-jerk reaction airy talk
wait I thought you're gonna be funny
come on no no no I'm not gonna be your
monkey they tried to turn it around and
he said I'm not your monkey and right
then I heard the sword go the fact that
crossfire is now something we see in the
rear view mirror
may be largely attributable to our
friend Jon Stewart then held up his
fractured mirror to the entire history
of the United States he and his show
writers published another best-selling
book America his daily show viewers 17%
from the previous year
during that same time ad revenue was
also up by August 2005 the show pulled
in 41 million dollars a stunning 100
percent increase his production company
busboy productions signed a development
deal with Comedy Central their first
project was a spin-off with daily show
series regular Stephen Colbert the
success of The Daily Show led to the
launch of The Colbert Report and these
were the most important 10
Falls of Comedy Central so it became
both a cultural force and a political
force and a very important business
force for Viacom all that was reflected
in a 2007 Pew Research study which named
John Stewart the fourth most admired
journalist in America
Bravo indeed guests lined up to get on
the show when you go on you do a show
they they come and they say don't try to
compete with John you know in the green
room before he said who would ever think
you're trying they could be little I
mean there are a lot of people who can
interview celebrities but I don't think
there are a lot of people who can
interview politicians and really know
what's going on and that's why he's good
because he's funny he's not a doofus you
know he's like smart really smart funny
the dirty little secret is the big shots
in the news business actually adore John
Stewart me Brian Williams has been on
The Daily Show many times and Ted Koppel
has been on and Bill O'Reilly has been
on and so Stewart has a way of poking
you in the eye and you still come back
for more
we have almost come to blows we get into
our Jersey thing we orbit each other
Walter Cronkite was a giant and injuries
that a man you looked up to is that a
man who I wanted to be when I was a kid
really yeah it was like carrot top to
you sitting across the fake desk from
Stewart has become the coolest stop on
the promotion circuit the odd mix of
guests include well-known stars and
unknown authors academics and government
officials anyone Stewart finds important
or who he thinks we should know more
about by 2008 The Daily Show was a
critical stop on the campaign circuit
Barack Obama's appearance brought in
nearly 3.6 million viewers was a Daily
Show record Stewart was on a roll until
he had a surprisingly low rated
performance as host of the 2006 Academy
Awards the Academy nevertheless invited
him back in 2008
but this time the news was even worse
his appearance was the lowest rated in
Oscar history Stuart retreated to what
he does best
I am the most trusted German back at his
desk he was ready to fight new battles
this is America how many people want to
pay for your neighbors Laura gets after
this outburst by CNBC host Rick Santelli
Stewart made headlines again challenging
the network and their coverage of the
financial crisis Mad Money host Jim
Cramer defended NBC and sparked a
showdown with Jon Stewart what Jon
Stewart did in his showdown with Jim
Cramer is not just take on a very
well-known CNBC host he took on all of
the financial coverage by those of us in
the news business and he ripped it to
shreds now whether you agree or disagree
with him he did his homework he's gone
so Jim you know would you ever say I've
said this or that or the other thing
blah blah blah and Jim's like I would
never say that never that would be
nothing I would ever say and then John's
like let's go to roll the tape roll to
12 no not to 12 you know I mean I gotta
tell you you know I understand you want
to make finance entertaining but it's
not a game
and III when I watch that I get I can't
tell you how angry that makes me the
confrontation made news all over the
country the President had talked earlier
in the day yesterday about watching it I
enjoyed it thoroughly the video of their
showdown went viral on the web it's his
right to do it and it's through those
moments the crossfire incident the
Kramer takedown that we've learned a lot
more about who John Stewart is
John was a very nice guy a good guy
hasn't forgotten his roots he's not full
of himself if you saw this he'd be
horrified right now yeah I stopped
interview about me are you doing it
would be uncomfortable
it's the fool the comedian who tells us
the truth he's the only one that we
believe but that is the cultural
phenomenon that really sums up Jon
Stewart aware of his growing cultural
influence Stewart organized his version
of a march on Washington the rally to
restore sanity his turn as an activist
for moderation will undoubtedly bring
him even greater attention the fact that
he's in the back of my mind when we
almost do something incredibly dumb or
banal on the air that is all you need to
know about Jon's role in our life and
society and media that's kind of perfect
but I've said such nice things about it
now I mean going over the top to be
honest he's not as smart as I've made
help he's not really as handsome either
and he's not as funny as me
[Music]
[Music]